now on some breaking news a trial date
has been set for former U.S president
Donald Trump to face charges of
withholding top secret documents well
let's go straight to our correspondent
Mike Hannah he joins me from Washington
DC Mike I see a federal judge has set
the 20th of May as the potential start
date for the trial talk us through that
timing I believe that's very close to
the Republican primary isn't it
yes indeed uh will the judge Eileen
Cannon has been hearing uh argument from
both sides uh the prosecution wanted the
trial to start as soon as December the
defense wanted the trial to start after
the elections because they argued very
strongly that the trial could impact on
Donald Trump's chances during those
elections in November but what she has
done is actually split the difference as
it were she's gone halfway between what
each side wants she's decided that the
trial will be set for two weeks
beginning May the 20th now that is bang
after the nomination period for the
Republican candidacy it is before the
election so this is going to have
potentially a major impact on the
election process itself
I'm like I know that everyone's had to
talk about it as a number of Republican
candidates have spoken about the whole
issue of this trial but do we yet have a
sense of how much this might really
impact things for Donald Trump
politically
well it's very difficult to tell because
once again in the whole scenario since
uh Trump was indicted on these 38 counts
along with his longtime Aid it has been
split very much between those who
support Donald Trump who reject the
charges those who oppose Donald Trump
who welcomed the charges saying that he
must be held accountable for these
actions so it is a divided country in
terms of the impact on Donald Trump and
in terms of the impact of the election
itself even within the Republican Party
there's been very strong criticism in
some quarters of these charges being
brought against Donald Trump I must add
one very important Point here as well
and that concerns the judge in this
trial Eileen Cannon now she was
appointed by Trump in 2020 she heard a
case in which the if the Trump
defense argued that she must bring in
outside review of the papers that the
FBI had seized from Trump's residence
now this was a very controversial
decision and was overruled by the appeal
court with some very harsh words for the
judge from that appeal court so clearly
here it appears the judge is now trying
to show that she is as little as even as
possible and that's another significance
in the fact that this trial date is set
halfway between what the prosecution
wanted and what the defense wanted not
giving an inch either way and Mike these
are also as we know not the only charges
that Trump faces can you remind us of
the various different charges that the
former president faces and how this sits
amidst all of that
well let's look at this particular case
it is 38 charges have been brought
against the former president and also
his aide Walter now to these uh charges
basically arise from the fact that he uh
took documents when he left the White
House but also very importantly that the
argument is that he attempted to conceal
the fact and then attempt to to obstruct
Justice when authorities wanted to
reclaim the documents so these are a
series of charges uh some linked to the
Espionage Act not that he's accused of
spying but the charges do fall under the
Espionage Act so you've got that but
you've also got the special prosecutor
Jack Smith who's brought these charges
looking into allegations of trump
attempting to subvert the results of the
January 20th election now as I speak
there is a grand jury sitting in DC
which is hearing evidence about this now
Trump has been issued a letter of demand
saying that he's a Target in this
investigation within coming days that
grand jury is likely to decide whether
or not Donald Trump is charged with
relation to that which is once again add
to these multiple charges uh that
President former president Trump is
facing Mike Hanna there with all the
latest for us from Washington DC
interesting times indeed thank you Mike